>> DAVID AXLEROD, ALWAYS A
PLEASURE, SIR.
THANK YOU.
>> THANK YOU.
>> GREAT TO SEE YOU GUYS.
>>> ALL RIGHT.
AHEAD, BILL MAHER, A MAN WITH A
LONG HISTORY OF AMUSING AND, YOU
KNOW, SOMETIMES OFFENDING, BOTH
ENDS OF THE POLITICAL SPECTRUM,
HE SAT DOWN WITH JAKE TAPPER FOR
THEIR SPECIAL.
IT AIRS TONIGHT 9:00 EASTERN ON
CNN.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> DO YOU THINK DEMOCRATIC
POLITICIANS HAVE CHANGED THEIR
VIEWS OR DO YOU THINK THEY ARE
AFRAID OF THEIR PARTY'S
ACTIVISTS THE WAY A LOT OF
REPUBLICANS ARE AFRAID OF THEIR
PARTY'S ACTIVISTS, THE MAGA
FOLKS.
>> B, THEY ARE AFRAID.
>> THEY ARE JUST AFRAID?
>> YES, I THINK BOTH SIDES.
AGAIN THERE ARE FOUR TRIBES IN
THIS COUNTRY.
THERE IS OLD SCHOOL LIBERALS AND
OLD SCHOOL CONSERVATIVES,
REPUBLICANS AND DEMOCRATS, THE
KIND OF PEOPLE WHO USED -- I
THINK THAT'S THE MAJORITY OF THE
COUNTRY.
>> HILLARY CLINTON AND JEB BUSH?
>> YEAH, THEY DIDN'T AGREE ON A
LOT BUT FOUND WAYS TO WORK
TOGETHER.
THEY DIDN'T HATE EACH OTHER.
IT WASN'T ALL ABOUT MAKING
LIBERAL TEARS AND CRY AND OWNING
AND DESTROYING PEOPLE.
IT WAS JUST, YEAH, I DON'T AGREE
WITH BOB DOLE BUT WE CAN WORK
TOGETHER, WE CAN GET A GRAND
BARGAIN, THAT KIND OF STUFF.
AND SO I THINK THAT'S THE
MAJORITY.
BUT THEN YOU HAVE TRUMPERS AND
THEN YOU HAVE WOKESTERS.
AND, YOU KNOW, THOSE FRIDGES ARE
NOT DOING THIS COUNTRY ANY GREAT
FAVORS.
>> JOINING US NOW IS CNN ANCHOR
AND CHIEF WASHINGTON
CORRESPONDENT JAKE TAPPER.
GOOD MORNING.
WHY DID YOU WANT TO SIT DOWN
WITH HIM?
WHAT'S THE MOST FASCINATING
TAKEAWAY?
>> WELL, YOU KNOW, I THINK HE'S
A ONE OF THE PREEMINENT
POLITICAL COMEDIANS IN THE
COUNTRY, IF NOT THE MOST, AND,
OBVIOUSLY, HE WORKS FOR HBO MAX,
OUR SISTER CHANNEL.
IT SEEMED LIKE A GREAT
OPPORTUNITY TO SIT DOWN, PICK
HIS BRAIN ABOUT POLITICS,
COMEDY, ANY NUMBER OF THINGS HE
TALKS ABOUT ON HIS SHOW FRIDAY
NIGHTS.
IT WAS AN INTERESTING WIDE
RANGING CONVERSATION ON A NUMBER
OF TOPICS.
>> HE IS PRETTY POLITICAL.
HE DELVES INTO THE POLITICAL
ISSUES.
MADE MILLION DOLLARS DONATIONES
IN THE PAST.
YOU TALKED TO HIM ABOUT THAT.
WHAT IS HIS TAKE ON WHAT WE'RE
PREDICTING FOR 2024?
WE WERE TALKING ABOUT DeSANTIS,
TRUMP, BIDEN, HIS AGE.
>> THOSE ARE A LOT OF TOPICS.
WE TALKED ABOUT EVERY ONE OF
THEM.
I THINK HE THINKS INEVITABLY
PROBABLY GOING TO BE BIDEN
VERSUS TRUMP ALTHOUGH HE IS NOT
100% SURE OF THAT.
HE THINKS BIDEN CAN DEFEAT
TRUMP.
HE THINKS THAT THE BIG FIELD OF
REPUBLICAN CANDIDATES TAKING ON
TRUMP IN THE REPUBLICAN PRIMARY
WILL LIKELY MEAN THAT TRUMP WINS
THE NOMINATION AGAIN.
HE WAS NOT PARTICULARLY
CONCERNED ABOUT BIDEN'S AGE.
THINKS HE IS ABLE TO DO THE JOB.
HE HAD A LOT TO SAY ABOUT HOW
MOST CULTURES HONOR THEIR ELDERS
AND SEEK ADVICE FROM THEM AND
THAT IS THE WAY HE SEES
PRESIDENT BIDEN, ALTHOUGH HE
CERTAINLY DISAGREES WITH QUITE A
BIT THAT BIDEN HAS DONE.
>> JAKE, FOR THOSE OF US WHO ARE
OLD ENOUGH TO REMEMBER, I MEAN,
BILL MAHER GOT CANCELED, RIGHT,
BACK IN THE DAY, POLITICALLY
INCORRECT.
HE GOT CANCELED BY THE RIGHT.
NOW HE SPEAKS --
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
>> HE SPEAKS ABOUT WOKISM AND
BEING CANCELED BY THE LEFT.
THIS MOLE BILL MAHER ARC HAS
BEEN FASCINATING TO WATCH AND
ESPECIALLY HIS STANCES ON, YOU
KNOW, WHO IS CANCELING AND WHO
IS RESPONSIBLE THESE DAYS.
>> YEAH.
POLITICALLY INCORRECT STARTED IN
THE '90s ON COMEDY CENTRAL,
TRANSFERRED -- WENT OVER TO ABC.
AND IT WAS AFTER THE GULF WAR
HAD STARTED, THE IRAQ WAR
STARTED RATHER, AND HE MADE A
COMMENT ABOUT WHETHER OR NOT
PEOPLE WHO ARE SUICIDE BOMBERS
OR PEOPLE ON PLANES SENDING
PLANES INTO BUILDINGS WHETHER
THAT IS COWARDLY AS OPPOSED TO
SENDING MISSILES OUT.
AND IT WAS -- HE WAS VERY
CRITICIZED AND THE BUSH
WHITEOUTS WEIGHED IN.
THEY SAID PEOPLE NEED TO WATCH
WHAT THEY SAY.
THE DISNEY-OWNED ABC CANCELED
HIM SOON AFTER THAT.
HE WOULD ARGUE HE HASN'T
CHANGED.
IT'S JUST THAT THE PEOPLE DOING
THE CANCELING HAVE CHANGED.
AND IT USED TO BE MORE PEOPLE ON
THE RIGHT AND NOW IT'S JUST AS
MANY, IF NOT MORE, PEOPLE ON THE
LEFT.
>> HE FAMOUSLY PREDICTED THAT
TRUMP WOULDN'T LEAVE THE WOWS.
WE ALL SAW WHAT PLAYED OUT.
DID YOU GUYS TALK ABOUT THAT?
>> WE DID.
QUITE A BIT.
I AM NOT SURE IF WE HAVE THE
MONTAGE READY OF THOSE CLIPS.
>> WE DO.
LET'S PLAY IT.
>> YEAH, LET'S WATCH THAT.
>> I DON'T SEE HIM LEAVING
WILLINGLY, UNDER ANY CONDITION,
INCLUDING PEOPLE KNOCKING ON THE
DOOR WITH GUNS.
HE WOULD BE "SCARFACE."
I DON'T THINK HE WOULD EVEN
LEAVE IF HE LOST AN ELECTION IN
2020.
PEOPLE SAIL I AM AN ALARMIST AND
I'M CRAZY BECAUSE I SAY HE IS
NOT GOING TO LEAVE IT HE LOSES.
I BET YOU $1 MILLION RIGHT NOW
IF YOU LOSE THE 2020 ELECTION I
AM RIGHT AND YOU WON'T LEAVE.
>> I SAID FOR A NUMBER OF YEARS
THAT IF TRUMP LOSES THE
ELECTION, HE IS NOT GOING TO
LEAVE.
>> I CANNOT PICTURE THAT MAN
GRACEFULLY CONCEDING AND WALKING
AWAY.
>> INTERESTING ONE OF THOSE
COMMENTS WAS TO STEVE BANNON, IF
YOU SAW THERE.
HE WAS SAYING THAT TO STEVE
BANNON.
I SAID, YOU KNOW, WHAT MADE YOU
PREDICT THAT?
HE SAID, HAVE YOU BEEN WATCHING
DONALD TRUMP?
LIKE IT WAS -- HE IS A GUY WHO
DOESN'T ACKNOWLEDGE EVER LOSING,
NEVER CONCEDES DEFEAT, NEVER
CONCEDES MISTAKE.
IT WAS PREDICTABLE.
>> IT'S GOING TO BE SHOCKING TO
SOME PEOPLE ON A DIFFERENT
LEVEL.
I DON'T KNOW IF YOU REMEMBER
THIS, JAKE.
I PREDICTED THAT, I SAID DONALD
TRUMP WILL PROBABLY WIN THIS --
THE ELECTION IN 2016.
LOOK, I LOST A LOT OF LIBERAL
FRIENDS.
GOT KICKED OUT OF PARTIES IN
BROOKLYN.
>> REALLY?
>> OH, MY GOSH, GENTLEMEN.
I SAID, HAVE YOU SEEN THE
NEWSPAPER?
THE NEWSPAPERS?
HE IS ON EVERY SECTION, ON THE
BUSINESS SECTION, ON THE
POLITICAL SECTION, ON THE REAL
ESTATE SECTION.
HE IS ON THE FRONT PAGES.
IT WAS JUST BECAUSE HE KNEW HOW
TO MANIPULATE AND USE THE MEDIA
AND SO IT'S INTERESTING TO, YOU
KNOW, SEE BILL MAHER SAY, HEY,
LISTEN, THIS GUY ISN'T GOING TO
LEAVE THE WHITE HOUSE.
THE EVIDENCE WAS THERE BUT
PEOPLE KIND OF IGNORED WHAT'S IN
FRONT OF THEIR FACES.
DO YOU THINK I AM WRONG ABOUT
THAT?
>> NO.
YOU REMIND ME OF THAT GREAT SKIT
ON "SATURDAY NIGHT LIVE" AFTER
TRUMP WAS ELECTED WHEN DAVE
CHAPPELLE AND CHRIS ROCK ARE AT
A PARTY WATCHING THE ELECTION.
NOT SURPRISED AT ALL.
>> THE TWO BLACK GUYS IN THE
ROOM GOING, WHY IS EVERYBODY
FREAKING OUT?
>> JAKE, THANK YOU.
>> THIS IS GOING TO HAPPEN.
WE KNEW THIS WAS GOING TO
HAPPEN.
THANKS, GUYS.
>> JAKE, ALWAYS A PLEASURE.
>> WATCH JAKE WITH BILL MAHER